we've worked very closely with the
raiders and we will continue to work
very closely with the raiders i'm not
sure that we agree that we've exhausted
all the options as
mike mayok said uh but there's no doubt
it's still an ongoing process we are
trying to work with the team and the
league and the union to come up with the
solution we haven't figured it out yet
to say that av is upset about the
decision to not let him wear his helmet
is accurate but we're still processing
it and figuring it out i wouldn't make
too much about him not being there today
as much as we're still trying to come up
with the solution that works
well antonio brown did return to the
raiders on monday that's the good news
for the organization to the extent that
gm mike mayok made the ultimatum on
sunday brown returned however
brown does not buy into the idea that
there's nothing more that can be done
chris sims as it relates to the helmet
issue because as we kind of surmised
yesterday his best option his only
option file another grievance unrelated
to the very weak and in my opinion
misguided grievance that was filed over
having the ability to wear the same
actual helmet for more than 10 years
noxi noc-sae the outside
agency that re-certifies or doesn't
re-certify helmets will not re-certify
any helmet that's more than 10 years old
different issue now antonio brown
realizes hey i can get the same model i
just get one that's less than 10 years
old i can wear that same model nfl
slamming the door on that loophole by
expedited testing of the shut air
advantage and antonio brown's argument
in this second grievance wait a minute
if you're just going to out of the blue
take my preferred helmet model add it to
the list of banned helmets when everyone
else whose helmet was banned got a one
year grace period to transition out of
that helmet i should get it too it's
that simple it's that straightforward
and we'll see whether or not an
arbitrator agrees with antonio brown but
that's where it's heading from now now
after this if he loses this one chris
there's really nothing else he can do
right but this one is stronger than the
last one in large part because the last
one was so ridiculously weak yes
i'm truly in tr intrigued by how the nfl
kind of dances around this or handles
this all together because i i know the
point you make and and the fact that
brady and rogers got that one-year grace
period and all that and 31 other guys in
the nfl totally get it and from that
standpoint so should antonio brown now
is the nfl gonna do that or they are
they finally just figuring out that they
had a real mess up here with not putting
this you know helmet along with the
other ones that were banned last year
and are they just going to say where the
nfl where the shield deal with it but
either way okay i'll just say this even
though i don't know how it's going to
shake out
either way
antonio brown's handling this poorly i
mean there's no other way to say this
you just can't be the best one of the
best players in football and be a guy
that gets all this new money from a team
and they expect you to come in there and
you know rejuvenize the organization and
you just walk out of practice or don't
show up on on on days where things don't
go your way that's just that's just not
good it's not a good professional it's
not good for the team it's a distraction
all of those things and that's where i'm
bothered more than anything by it at
this point
hang on i got to make a note here
august 20
2019
rejuvenize
the latest edition i guess in the chris
sims dictionary the alternative english
dictionary when you're represented and
energized together it's rejuvenized
it can it can have quite a dramatic
effect
here's the thing uh
yeah i think what's going on here is the
nfl knows that they screwed up by not
testing the air advantage when they did
all the other helmets it just fell into
a crevice and they just didn't notice it
even though
antonio brown was wearing the shutter
advantage on the cover of the madden
game last year they just didn't test it
and between
not wanting to acknowledge that they
made a mistake and not wanting antonio
brown to win they're going to fight this
now an independent neutral arbitrator
will decide whether or not antonio brown
gets to wear his helmet model of choice
and uh
both sides have their arguments i think
antonio brown's argument is better
because i think he should get the same
one-year grace period that other players
who were told a year ago hey your
helmet's unsafe you can't wear it
anymore but we're going to give you a
year to get used to this new reality he
should get the same treatment but as you
said it's still not being handled the
right way and everything that's going on
with antonio brown from the frozen feet
fiasco to the helmet issue to leaving
camp on multiple occasions and not being
there with his teammates we put out a
question earlier on twitter and it was
worded like this if the raiders could go
back to march and pass on the trade for
antonio brown do you think they would
not do you think they should do you
think they would so far over 13 000
votes
73 percent say yes they think they would
although whoever whoever made the
screenshot voted no
yeah right right
i i don't think they're they're they're
in that territory yet i don't think
they're regretting it yet now if they
get through four or five weeks in the
season and the play is not good along
with some of these distractions they had
to deal with they might regret it then
but right now i think they're still
expecting wow we got one of the best
weapons in the sport and he's gonna lead
football and receiving yards and targets
and receptions and all that to where a
lot of this can be swept under the rug
with good play on the field but i ask
you this counselor
what do you think is going to happen for
you what will happen do you think the
nfl is going to give them the grace
period or you think they're going to lay
the law down and say no dice here
oh it all depends on what the arbitrator
does and i know that sounds like a cop
out that is a total cop-out
i just want your gut feeling can i
finish no i don't want to hear it yes
i'm trying to i'm trying to rejuvenize
the show here please
um listen when i practice law i always
told people because i get that from my
clients hey hey what's going to happen i
don't know what's going to happen and
anybody who acts like they know how any
type of legal or quasi-legal proceeding
is going to work out if they tell you
they know they're either lying or
they're stupid or they're both nobody
knows there's an independent arbitrator
i don't know who it is i don't know this
person's background i don't know whether
they're going to be more likely to see
it antonio brown's way or see at the
nfl's way it's impossible to know where
that decision is going to go without
knowing who's going to make the decision
and we did research all the time on who
the judges are who the jurors are you
have to know who the people are to know
how they're going to react to the
argument but i think you can make a very
compelling argument if you're antonio
brown look they are on the fly
identifying my preferred helmet model as
one that can't be worn even though they
never did before so now that they're
doing it i should get the same one-year
grace period right that the guys got
last year that is a strong argument and
i think that if you frame it that way it
has a chance to win assuming the
arbitrator okay
are you done being a lawyer what's your
gut say what does your gut say tell me
your gut
it's probably gonna lose okay me too i
feel that way
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports